[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition de votre
journal d'information au quotidien sur
tv 60,18 voici les titres de ce 20
novembre
l'impact challenge google france 2019 a
livré son palmarès bien que lauréate les
deux entreprises de saint quentin en
yvelines web force 3 et o clock ne monte
pas sur le podium
elles repartent néanmoins avec 150000
euros chacune afin de faire du numérique
un synonyme d'opportunités
tous les détails à suivre franck ferrand
laurent joffrin jean tulard pour ne
citer qu'eux leur passion commune
l'histoire ses auteurs de romans
d'essais de bd même seront présents à
versailles
les 23 et 24 novembre pour le 12e salon
histoire de lire le commissaire de
l'événement est l'invité du journal ce
soir et puis politique également à
suivre avec françois morton le maire de
guyancourt qui a hérité de l'écharpé
tricolore en mai dernier avec la
démission de marie christine le tarnec
sera candidat tête de liste en 2020 nous
parlerons avec lui est de son bilan et
de son programme valorisé à l'inclusion
par le numérique un objectif se
développé par google à travers son
impact challenge un prix pour aider les
associations ou les entreprises à
réaliser ou conforter leur projet parmi
les dix finalistes désignées par des
votes sur internet deux entreprises
présentes sur saint quentin en yvelines
o clock et web force 3 le reportage de
marie lehn yapi chine aujourd'hui en
france
sont encore éloignés c'est en partant de
ce constat que google a décidé de lancer
son challenge en france des prix
récompensant des projets valorisants
l'inclusion numérique
il ya des organisations vraiment
innovant est ici qui ont des idées pour
savoir être à proximité de l'inclusion
et on voulait être à côté des meilleures
idées des entrepreneurs à travers le
pays est procuré l'aide dont ils ont
besoin et de trouver au mieux des
volontaires pour google
parmi les 250 candidatures dix projets
ont été retenus finalistes chaque
représentant avait une minute trente
pour séduire le jury et 3 minutes 30
pour répondre à leurs questions parmi
eux deux centres de formation active
dans les yvelines o'clock une école qui
forme au métier de développeur web via
des classes virtuelles
c'est vraiment un gros travail à la
hauteur de l'enjeu aussi le pitch était
aussi beaucoup de stress mais bon
maintenant
maintenant que c'est passé on peut en
parler de manière assez apaisés on est
on est tous content de l'avoir fait et
web for 3 pour son programme de
formation numérique dédié aux personnes
en situation de handicap
s'ils ne font pas partie des cinq
lauréats comme tous les finalistes
il remporte tout de même une dotation de
150 mille euros je pense que ce qui va
être très important c'est que en plus de
la subvention
de manière égale pour les dix quand les
10 lauréats et
il va y avoir du mécénat de compétences
de google et dans d'autres cas c'est
assez important parce qu'on a besoin
d'une aide sur le plan technologique
pour construire ce dispositif ordi forte
chez les deux grands gagnants sont le
carillon qui propose des solutions
d'accès au numérique pour les sans
domicile fixe prix du public et connexio
qui aide les personnes en recherche
d'emploi à accéder aux compétences
numériques premier prix du jury nous par
toi à maurepas où le marché affiche
dorénavant un nouveau visage depuis ce
week-end une vingtaine de commerçants
est installée est sous une valve
temporaire l'installation a été mise en
place par la mairie après l incendie qui
a touché la structure en bois du marché
permanent en juillet dernier
la solution va être maintenu jusqu'à la
reconstruction prévue dans deux ans
mélanie poker
c'était une halle attendu les 800 m²
accueille depuis le 16 novembre une
vingtaine de commerçants principalement
de l'alimentaire une mise à l'abri en
cette période de froid la mairie nous a
gâté quand même vraiment là malheur on
arrive sur quelque chose de positif à
ces supers souvenirs surtout pour les
commerçants d'arrêter la mort du marché
ainsi danger on peut penser d'abord aux
marchands forains qui doit apprécier
d'être un peu à l'abri par rapport aux
semaines passées
donc oui c'est une bonne initiative de
la mairie un marché perturbé ces
derniers mois après l'incendié de là à
le 31 juillet une quarantaine de
commerçants s'y retrouvent deux fois par
semaine certains d'entre eux ont vu une
baisse de leur activité
nos commerçants sont importants pour la
ville de mort pas c'est un marché qui
rayonne et qui était intercommunale et
donc je me devais en tout cas en tant
que maire et aussi avec mon équipe
d'apporter ce plus pour garantir de
passe et j'allais dire le froid l'hiver
dans de bonnes conditions
les installations seront pérennes il n'y
aura plus l'installation et la
désinstallation
donc ça c'est vraiment un gain de temps
et de confort pour nos commerçants dont
quotidien de ronds sur marché le
mercredi matin et le samedi matin
une consultation publique débutera en
début d'année 2020 la commune espère la
livraison de la nouvelle halle pour 2022
comme chaque année il revient le
beaujolais nouveau sera lancée demain et
pourquoi ne pas le découvrir à elancourt
ou le restaurant les templiers s'est
associé avec le coin et du sommelier une
ancienne située sur maurepas il propose
dorénavant un nouveau concept aux
clients et plus de 600 références des
champagnes des spiritueux et bien
évidemment des vins sont proposés comme
chaque troisième jeudi du mois de
novembre les adeptes du beaujolais
nouveau attendent avec impatience sa
sortie officielle le coin du sommelier
barre avant de maurepas et les templiers
restaurant gastronomique d'elancourt
viennent de s'associer
il propose un concept plus élargie il
dispose à présent d'une vraie cave à vin
plaisir d'avoir notre cave en fait dans
le restaurant c'est de pouvoir faire
partager notre passion du vin
à nos clients et de pouvoir leur faire
accorder leur mais que ce soit du canard
que ce soit de la viande que ce soit du
poisson avec toute la multitude de ces
pages qu'on a aucun restaurant et coin
du sommelier 600 références sont
proposées aux clients
on va démarrer avec à peu près 450
références devant une cinquantaine de
références de champagne et entre 150 et
200 références de spiritueux quand je
parle de spiritueux je parle de rome de
whisky de tequila de jean par tous les
alcools qui dépasse 18 2
les prix des bouteilles varie de 6 euros
et peuvent monter jusqu'à 1000 euros
pour les grands crus classés si la
bouteille et consommer sur place un
droit de bouchon de 15 euros est alors
appliqué on peut venir ici à la cave a
acheté sa bouteille
donc le prix qu à vis comme tout le
monde comme si on allait chez un caviste
indépendants ou alors on reste ici et à
ce moment là on applique le droit de
bouchon si on conserve la bouteille sur
place si on termine pas sa bouteille
bien évidemment on peut repartir avec
une dégustation est proposée aux
templiers à la commanderie de
lavilledieu d'elancourt demain à
l'occasion du beaujolais nouveau de
18h30 à 22h avec des animations loisirs
elle et lui dit dave qui se poursuivent
à saint quentin en yvelines c'est dans
ce cadre que s'est déroulé le week-end
dernier à villepreux la cinquième
édition du festi jeu l'occasion de
découvrir le jeu sous toutes ses formes
de rôles d'adressent ou encore deux
plateaux on à l'association de la leaf
qui est présente ce sont des auteurs de
jeux de société qui sont venus à faire
tester leur prototype donc c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer des auteurs de
jeux et puis de participer au
développement différents jeux donc ils
sont sept auteurs présents sur le
surtout le festival un événement qui a
rassemblé près de 3500 personnes durant
ces deux jours noté que le 23 novembre
aura lieu la nuit du jeu au mime aide
pour clore donc celui d'ideye elle c'est
à montigny le bretonneux invités de
cette édition qui avait mal un bon soir
vous êtes l le commissaire du salon
histoire de lire 12e édition 23 24
novembre à versailles trois sites
hôtel de ville hôtel du département et
préfectures également l'an dernier plus
de 170 hauteur 20 milles 1 mille
visiteurs schneider 20 millions on n'y
est pas encore je vous le souhaite mais
vingt mille visiteurs quels sont les
objectifs pour cette année est d'aller
en
plus loin d'accueillir encore plus de
monde notre adn n'a pas changé
effectivement depuis douze ans c'est la
passion de l'histoire que l'on veut que
l'heureux transmettent voilà on navigue
bien sûr les passionnés d'histoire mais
mais tout le monde est concerné par ce
retour sur sur ce qu'on fait de bien ou
le mal et les anciens et qui peuvent
nous nous concerne et voilà donc on a
des choses à apprendre
il faut le faire aussi en salle au
s'amusant voilà on aime on aime qu'il y
ait du plaisir à découvrir des éléments
de la programmation cette année on va
recevoir par exemple la grande catherine
pas de russie catherine nay la grande
journaliste
voilà qui a connu personnellement tous
les grands chefs d'état depuis de gaulle
et qui dans ses mémoires souvenirs
souvenirs va va nous raconter peut-être
des éléments bien sûr de la grande
histoire mais aussi des l'envers des
anecdotes très personnelles dans
l'intimité de c2c président de la
république de la vème république
quel est l'objectif premier de ce salon
c'est de démocratiser un peu cette
histoire de faire venir des écrivains
reconnus connu reconnu d'autres un peu
plus populaires peut-être aussi d'autres
moins connus et de partager l'histoire à
travers le livre oui c'est votre c'est
vraiment ça un peuple qui qui qui aime
son histoire qui qui se passionnent qui
s'instruit et est un peuple qui peut se
projeter regarder l'avenir sereinement
et donc notre objectif effectivement
c'est de transmettre au plus grand
nombre donc effectivement ddd des
journalistes des comédiens des hommes
politiques sont aussi là parce qu on est
tous concernés par par l'histoire et
l'écriture de l'histoire
si on fait le tour un petit peu des
auteurs qui seront présents alors ce
sera l'occasion de les rencontrer
d'échanger avec eux de faire dédicacer
aussi pourquoi pas mais d'en savoir un
peu plus sur les livres qu'ils écrivent
si on fait le tour de ses historiens il
est des écrivains de tous les horizons y
en a qui viennent de l'étranger aussi
alors il y aller les grandes plumes les
sommités qui font l'histoire vous citiez
jean tulard hélène carrère d'encausse
voilà jean christian petitfils ils sont
ils sont là mais on a aussi des grands
passeurs franck ferrand par exemple
vient de sortir et sera là vient de
sortir de livres cette année dont un
livre très très très personnel très
intime où il remonte sur
en france pour nous expliquer comment il
est tombé dans le chaudron chaudron de
l'histoire la passion de l'histoire
voilà la bande dessinée la bande
dessinée ski à tous les genres la parole
a forcément du roman mais n'y a pas fait
le roman il ya tous les genres bande
dessinée mais nous recevons blake et
mortimer qui sort en sortie mondiale le
dernier album donc la vallée des
immortels sort ce week end en tout temps
sur la planète et nous aurons les
auteurs belges qui viennent à versailles
s'il vous plaît avec un débat assez
amusant puisque ils vont débattre avec
un ancien ministre hubert védrine qui
vient d'écrire un livre sur la
biographie non autorisée de olrik vous
savez le cadre elle avec le méchant donc
paraît-il monsieur védrine avec l'aide
de son fils laurent nous apporte la
preuve que rick réellement existé et qui
l'a inspiré jacobs dans la création
blake et mortimer de ce personnage une
histoire de lire point fr pour avoir le
programme complet il ya les auteurs a
rencontré vous en avait parlé il ya des
rencontres il ya des débats qui sont
aussi programmés sur les trois sites que
je citais tout à l'heure sur versailles
bd romans et aussi du coloriage très
très jeune on peut s'initier aux
plaisirs du livre d'histoire tout à fait
vous avez cité les différents espaces
mais on a aussi un chapiteau une tente
avec 2 35 auteurs pour la jeunesse dès
le premier âge
et puis vous parler peut-être d'aidé
youtuber il ya même un prix qui sera
remis également maintenant aujourd'hui
effectivement le savoir l'histoire se
passe aussi sur internet et les youtuber
aussi en ont fait leur spécialité pour
quelques-uns c'est un vrai phénomène
alors on connaît le phénomène sur
youtube mais youtube et l'histoire ça
fonctionne très fort on a lancé ce prix
là une hernie il y avait une vingtaine
de jeunes qui ont concouru cette année
nous avons 40 et est donc la remise du
prix qui sera présidé par franck ferrand
c'est ce vendredi donc à l'ugc cyrano il
reste encore des places donc nous
invitons les auditeurs de tesson visite
à venir notons le jeune génération à
découvrir voilà parce qu ils sont
créatifs
ils sont créatifs quel regard vous
portez justement sur ces créations de
youtube heures en termes de façon dont
ils abordent l'histoire c'était un
phénomène vous le disais un peu nouveau
lorsque vous avez fondé salon est
maintenant 12 ans ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui ça se développe
quel regard vous portez vous dit que
c'est une évolution
naturel normal c'est un phénomène pour
l'instant encore à la marge et peut-être
qu'ils pourraient disparaître ou qu'il
ya trois ans quand j'ai vu observé ça
peut-être que je n'aurais pas le même
discours aujourd'hui benjamin brio de la
chaîne nota bene a dépassé le million
d'abonnés si vous voulez donc j'allais
dire des les chaînes hertziennes les les
grandes émissions d'histoire ne peuvent
commencer à s'inquiéter parce que cette
génération voilà assure la relève
moi je les vois comme enfin c'est ce
qu'on va discuter vendredi avec le jury
mais mais y'a du yalu qualitative ya
beaucoup de professeurs d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont bêtes peut être en cours et
qui le soir créé leur vidéo pour sortir
des cô tes classiques de la transmission
obligatoire du programme et donc ils
s'amusent sur des sujets je pense que
c'est les voilà les alains de coller les
passeurs d'aujourd'hui mais on observait
avec attention et un certain nombre sont
déjà passées aux livres voilà nous avons
bâti ce corps d'abbas je citais bages un
brio qu'on écrit des livres qui seront
là pendant le salon aussi pour dédicacer
leur livre le prix de youtube heures
c'est le vendredi 22 novembre celle du
cirano je redonne le site internet il
s'est affiché histoire de lire point fr
vous aurez tout le programme
quelle est l'ambition que vous fixé pour
ce salon pour le développer encore
aujourd'hui à toute une équipe
il ya plus d'une centaine de bénévoles
qui sont aussi mobilisés vous êtes
partis surtout petit salon on va dire et
qui aujourd'hui devenu un salon
incontournable
quelle est la prochaine étape alors la
prochaine étape je ne la connais pas
encore
ce qui est vrai c'est que on développe
beaucoup d actions en amont du salon
tout le mois de novembre on ne le sait
pas mais nous faisons des rencontres
avec des collégiens où on envoie en
mission d des professeurs on offre des
cartes cadeaux offerts par le
département des yvelines et se permet
aux enfants de venir consommer acheter
repartir avec un livre cette année on a
lancé des des projets issus des
projections de documentaires historiques
avec la chaîne histoire là il ya
pratiquement 1000 collégiens qui sont
passées à écouter ses documentaires et
ensuite discuté avec un historien
pendant pendant une heure voilà donc je
voudrais que l'on colons délai l'énergie
effectivement de développer ça c'est à
dire les publics les plus les plus
éloignés d'eux
la lecture et de la culture historique
sont notre priorité pour les années à
venir à plus de 20000 visiteurs sur ces
deux jours 23 24 novembre
nous y serons bien évidemment et puis
nous en rendrons compte dans le
prochaine édition dans une prochaine
édition du journal merci encore d'être
passé sur ce plateau
rendez vous donc pour histoire de lire à
versailles changement d'univers à
présent comme chaque semaine nous
faisons le tour des salles de cinéma en
ce jour de sortie aujourd'hui vos
réactions au deuxième volet de la reine
des neiges et nana et elsa à part dont
sont de retour voici vos avis j'entends
une voix une voix commencent à une très
belle suite avec un scénario qui est
assez inattendu souvent on se dit que
les deuxièmes parties sont un peu
décevantes et là pour le coup vraiment
une très belle réalisation et beaucoup
d'émotion sur le coup j'ai pas trop
accroché parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
musique et je me suis dit que ce serait
que tu y aurait que des paroles en
musique puis après je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait beaucoup d'action
et tout ça et ça m'a beaucoup plu
elles avaient des talons blanc les
talons bleus et la changer de couette
elle a défait sa tresse elle allie la
ligne que tu vas aller après la lâcher
ses cheveux j'ai bien aimé
alors pourquoi te le bien aimé est ce
que ça faisait un petit peu peur mais
j'aime bien être qui font peur
l'histoire les musiques ça c'est ma
petite fille qui va faire la réflexion
qui a vu la première
la première version elle m'a signalé
quand même que les musiques étaient trop
et d'antiques dans la reine des neiges
deux mois
y'a pas à libérer des livres et c'est
pas le jouer je crois en toi y va
scande importe qui et n'importe quoi
nous passons à l'interview politique de
ce 20 novembre avec françois morton
bonsoir vous êtes le maire de guyancourt
candidat à un nouveau mandat bien que mr
c'est votre première campagne en tant
que tête de liste cette fois-ci 2014 je
restitue françois de ligne est élu il
démissionne en 2016 marie-christine le
tarnais qui devient mère elle quitte à
son tour le poste pour des raisons de
santé
nous sommes en maître 2019 vous devenez
mer cette mandature a été agitée dans
les rangs de la majorité
est ce qu'il faut le traduire comme ça
alors oui on nous renvoie effectivement
très souvent les trois maires durant
demande à françois de ligné a été maire
pendant 14 ans il a expliqué
effectivement les raisons de son départ
et c'était important cette action de
passer la main cette transmission se
relaient marie-christine le tarnec je ne
vais pas en dire plus ou là vous avez
tout dit on n'attend pas envisager des
raisons de santé
et j'étais son premier adjoint d'une
manière très cohérente et très logique
je suis devenue maman de mai dernier qui
est pour mener le travail au quotidien
mené le projet au quotidien durant ces
cinq ans les choses ont pu se faire est
ce que aujourd'hui déjà d'une part vous
assumez pleinement ce bilan de cette
équipe sortante même si elle a été elle
a évolué et puis quel regard vous portez
sur le travail réalisé ces cinq
dernières années alors le regard que je
porte sur sur le mandat sur
l'intégralité du mandat alors est-ce une
particularité je ne sais pas mais
toujours est il que l'ensemble des
engagements qui avaient été faits en
2014 ont été tenus ou sont en voie de
l'être
donc j'ai envie de dire que par le fait
j'assume pleinement évidemment ses
engagements et ce mandat et
l'intégralité de ce mandat
maintenant nous avons agi effectivement
en sorte et nous avons tenu de
l'ensemble de ses mandats je pense à
quelques exemples la réhabilitation du
my des sols par exemple qui était un
engagement la réalisation d'un relais
d'assistants maternels qui était
également un engagement et nous avons
été au delà car il faut aussi tenir
compte de l'adaptation durant le mandat
nous avons donc eu un certain nombre de
réalisations qui n'était pas mais qui
était en plus voilà donc peut-être vous
parlez de d'assumer donc ce mandat ces
réalisations pleinement 2014 françois de
ligne
était un parti socialiste de liste parti
socialiste aujourd'hui vous vous
présentez comme divers gauche oui est ce
que votre liste aura une investiture des
soutiens ou est-ce que vous restez sur
cette étiquette plus large alors
l'étiquette et les divers gauche a des
très simple à expliquer je n'adhère à
aucun parti politique
et comme il a été historiquement le cas
pour la liste guyancourt pour tous
personne ne demandait une adhésion à un
parti politique pour faire partie de
cette liste
on a besoin de citoyens engagés qui
veulent effectivement s'engager pour
l'heure leur ville et ce sera encore le
cas
ce coup ci pas de soutiens pas
d'investiture non en tout cas
officiellement vous ne demandez pas si
on vous l'accordé imagine annoncé l'otan
l'événement demande aucune et je n'ai eu
aucune proposition vous étiez 25e sur la
liste en 2014 ensuite vous êtes devenu
premier adjoint ensuite mr j'imagine que
le parcours vous n'y avais pas pensé
auparavant
c'est assez inattendu c'est assez
surprenant est ce que vous vous êtes
posé la question ensuite lorsqu'il a
fallu très vite se décider et être tête
de liste et candidat puisque vous êtes
devenu l'air en mai dernier une étape
intermédiaire que vous n'avez pas cité
c'est que j'ai été adjoint avant d'être
premier adjoint aussi donc effectivement
j'ai eu ce parcours-là qui n'était comme
vous l'avez dit pas prévu au démarrage
il ya une cohérence dans ce parcours
j'étais adjoint très rapidement puisque
dès le mois de novembre 2014 j'étais
adjoint donc j'ai été assez peu
longtemps conseiller municipal délégué
mes adjoints dès novembre 2014 et
premier adjoint 2016 donc le parcours il
peut sembler effectivement assez rapide
mais il a sa cohérence
il ya eu un renouvellement un changement
en tout cas au sein du conseil municipal
on l'a vu pendant le mandat est ce que
votre liste sera va repartir avec les
mêmes éléments est ce qu'il ya des
changements on a vu des candidatures se
déclarer je concède olivier paréja par
exemple qui était sur votre liste
en 2014 qui aujourd'hui est tête de
liste pour un autre mouvement
il va y avoir une recomposition une
évolution alors oui heureusement j'ai
envie dire que c'est assez traditionnel
le taux de renouvellement il est assez
traditionnel d'environ 50% ce sera
probablement effectivement le même la
même configuration pour ce mandat et
c'est normal on a besoin d'une ossature
à la fois d'élus expérimentés et de
terrain parce que tous les élus sont des
élus de terrain je me dis toujours donc
forcément expérimenté c'est important et
c'est pas simple toujours de gérer une
ville faut jamais l'oublier
et puis c'est important d'avoir aussi de
nouveaux élus avec un regard
avec une vision nouvelle de la ville de
guyancourt et plusieurs listes à gauche
ce n'est pas un regret ne pas réussir à
fédérer plus largement on peut le
regretter
on peut le regretter je ne peux que le
regretter ce n'est pas mon choix
voilà c'est plutôt le choix d'autres
listes je ne sais pas s'il ya d'autres
listes de gauche en l'occurrence voilà
il y aura celle en tout cas déclarés
d'olivier paréja qui qui porte un
mouvement participatif nous en avons
parlé lors des précédentes éditions du 7
8 politique parlant de votre programme
à présent solidarité éducation
développement durable ce sont les trois
axes principaux
oui alors c'était les axes principaux
j'ai envie de dire du monde a déjà 2014
2020 et j'ai presque envie de dire que
nous nous basons sur des convictions et
des valeurs
effectivement qui sont les valeurs de
notre liste c'est à dire une liste de
gauche je le dis toujours alors c'est
ses valeurs et ses convictions et ses
piliers il existe toujours bien
évidemment mais on peut aussi envisager
et c'est le cas actuellement puisque
vous savez probablement nous sommes sur
des ateliers de construction de ce
programme dont ce programme n'est
évidemment pas figé hier soir j'étais
encore avec environ 80 habitants de la
ville de guyancourt et nous continuerons
à construire ce programme et d'autres
thématiques évidemment émergeront ce
sera le 30 novembre prochain la
prochaine réunion la restitution de
l'ensemble de ces ateliers puisqu'il y
en a eu 2 les deux derniers mariés aura
lieu le 30 novembre prochain à 10h du
matin effectivement d'enquêté de
villageois ont parlé de ces trois axes
du programme est ce que la sécurité
aussi rentrer en ligne de compte
aujourd'hui on voit dans la plupart des
communes la sécurité est une demande
importante de la part des concitoyens ou
alors il faut la traiter avec sérieux en
a qu'on l'appelle sécurité on appelle
tranquillité publique on peut l'appeler
de livernon mais bien sûr ça doit être
traitée avec le plus grand sérieux
voilà alors on le traite tout au long du
mandat on la traitait tout au long du
mandat il ya eu des évolutions dans
notre politique de tranquillité publique
je pense notamment avec la création d'un
nouveau somme de sécurité urbaine un
développement des cadres des caméras de
vidéosurveillance etc
donc tout ça effectivement ce sont déjà
des choses qui se sont passées
maintenant je crois que la tranquillité
publique celle affaire de tous et on en
voit souvent la tranquillité publique à
la police municipale par exemple mais
tout ça est bien évidemment
puis rifaat auriez plus de
vidéosurveillance quels sont les
engagements vous allez prendre par
exemple alors le déploiement et le
développement des caméras de
vidéosurveillance il se fait il doit
toujours se faire d'une manière
pertinente c'est à dire que ce n'est pas
parce qu'à un moment donné constater
effectivement un fait donc nous
demandons toujours la vie de la police
nationale c'est important d'avoir ce
support est de plus en plus nous faisons
ça en concertation avec les habitants
voilà parce que ce sont des experts
aussi de leur cage d'escalier de leur
immeuble de leur résidence et on le fait
toujours sur le terrain avec les
habitants guyancourt est une ville qui a
beaucoup évolué en termes urbain aussi
ces dernières années il ya eu un
renouvellement ya des réalisations
aujourd'hui la ville est achevé où il ya
encore d'autres projets que vous
aimeriez mené lors d'un prochain mandat
alors j'espère bien que la ville n'est
pas achevé voilà nous avons bien
évidemment de grands projets et chacun
le sait nous avons un projet on va dire
à 10 ans avec en 2030 l'arrivée la mise
en service du métro de la ligne 18 donc
forcément avec le quartier qui
accueillera la gare donc c'est un projet
en projet à 10 ans avec des étapes
successives qui vont faire que ce
quartier va sortir de terre
mais vous parlez d'urbanisation il est
nécessaire de continuer à construire des
logements à guyancourt comme ailleurs
d'ailleurs mais toujours d'une manière
raisonnée et maîtrisé c'est à dire des
logements sociaux mais pas uniquement
sur guyancourt aujourd'hui c'est 50 %
logement social autour de 48 % de
logements sociaux actuellement sur la
ville de bus en cours alors moi ce que
je souhaite c'est de conserver des
équilibres c'est à dire que chacun
puisse trouver à se loger sur la ville
de lui en cours que ce soit des
étudiants et nous travaillons notamment
par exemple avec le crous en ce sens
mais aussi des revenus très modestes
dans le cadre par exemple du logement
social
et puis dans l'accession aidée ou pas
vous parliez du crous ce qui nous amène
à l'université aussi également
l'université qui va entrer pleinement
dans l'université paris saclay
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui est implantée sur sur
guyancourt c'est un enjeu aussi ce
développement et ces mutualisations
alors avec l'agglomération dont vous
faites partie de saint quentin en
yvelines mais aussi de paris saclay oui
c'est très important de conserver enfin
cette université on sait qu'elle est
amenée à se développer et heureusement
j'étais fière présent lors de la
i de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur à l'université nous avons pu
échanger et nous avons beaucoup de
projets autour de cette université et
elle doit pleinement faire partie
effectivement de ce plus grand ensemble
le prochain rendez vous pour vous le 30
novembre oui tout à fait date qui sont
déjà prévus alors il y aura par la suite
des réunions publiques bien évidemment
et nous y reviendrons merci françois
morton d'être revenus sur ce plateau en
début de campagne pour les municipales
sur lui en cours je rappelle que trois
autres listes se présentent pour
l'instant olivier paréja avec déciderons
ensemble à guyancourt grégory pape pour
la république en marche et rodolphe
barry sans étiquette mais soutenu par
génération de terrain c'est la fin de ce
journal nous nous retrouverons demain
jeudi et il sera très largement question
de la nouvelle édition pardon du sky
business days au vélodrome nationale
opération porté par l'agglomération de
saint quentin très bonne soirée
[Musique]